In addition to having query ID and randomization of that ID, the resolver can
randomize the source port on which it
sends the query, thereby adding an additional 16
bits of entropy to the ID that's
associated with the query. Unfortunately, picking a random
source port can be resource intensive and
also a network address translator or a NAT,
could derandomize the port. Another defense is called the 0x20 or the zero x20
encoding, which is based on the intuition that DNS matching and resolution
is entirely case insensitive. So capitalization
of individual letters in the domain name
do not affect the answer that the resolver will return. This 0x20 bit,
or the bit that affects whether a
particular character is capitalized or in lower case
can also be used to introduce additional entropy.
When generating a response to a query such
as this one, the query is copied from the DNS query into the response exactly
as it was in the query. The mixed pattern of upper and lower case letters thus
constitutes a channel. If the resolver and the
authoritative server can agree on a shared key,
then the resolver and the authoritative are the
only ones who know the appropriate pattern of
upper and lower case letters for a particular
domain name. Because no attacker would know the
appropriate combination of upper and lower case letters
for a particular domain. It becomes even more difficult
for the attacker to inject a bogus reply,
because not only would the attacker have to guess
the ID, but the attacker would also have to
guess the capitalization sequence for any particular domain name.